PERTINENT TO THE D.A.'S
INVESTIGATION.
PLENTY TO GET THROUGH.
>> THANK YOU FOR ALL OF THAT
REPORTING.
LET'S BRING IN CNN LEGAL
ANALYST, ELIE HONIG, THE FORMER
ASSISTANT U.S. ATTORNEY FOR THE
SOUTHERN DISTRICT OF NEW YORK.
GREAT TO HAVE YOU HERE.
WHAT POTENTIAL CRIMES IS THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY LOOKING AT?
>> ALISYN, THE D.A. HAS GIVEN US
PRETTY CLEAR CLUES AS TO WHERE
SHE'S FOCUSED.
IN HER LETTER ASKING JUDGES TO
APPOINT THIS SPECIAL GRAND JURY,
SHE HAS A QUOTE REASONABLE
PROBABILITY THAT THE STATE OF
GEORGIA'S ADMINISTRATION OF
ELECTIONS IN 2020 WAS SUBJECT TO
POSSIBLE CRIMINAL DISRUPTIONS.
NOW, UNDER GEORGIA LAW, IT IS A
CRIME TO SOLICIT, MEANING JUST
TO ASK SOMEBODY TO COMMIT
ELECTION FRAUD, AND THAT
INCLUDES WILLFULLY TAMPERING
WITH VOTES OR CERTIFICATION.
THE TERM WILLFULLY IS REALLY
IMPORTANT.
WHAT THAT MEANS LEGALLY IS THEY
KNEW WHAT THEY WERE DOING WAS
WRONG AND AGAINST THE LAW.
TO THAT POINT, LOOK FOR
PROSECUTORS TO FOCUS ON, YES,
THE INFAMOUS CALL FROM DONALD
TRUMP TO BRAD RAFFENSPERGER UGH
ALL I WANT TO DO IS THIS, FIND
11,780 VOTES, WHICH IS ONE MORE
THAN WE CAN, HERE'S THE KEYWORD,
PROSECUTORS ARE GOING TO SAY WHY
FIND, IF HE REALLY THOUGHT HE
WON, AND WHY EXACTLY THAT MANY
VOTES, ONE MORE THAN HE NEEDED.
THAT'S GOING TO BE A KEY LEGAL
QUESTION HERE.
>> WHO ELSE MIGHT THEY BE
LOOKING AT?
>> BIG NAMES HERE AS SUBJECTS OR
WITNESSES, LINDSEY GRAHAM
REPORTEDLY CALLED BRAD
RAFFENSPERGER, THE GOVERNOR OF
GEORGIA WAS CALLED BY DONALD
TRUMP WHO ASKED HIM TO CONVENE A
SPECIAL SESSION OF THE GEORGIA
LEGISLATURE, THE GEORGIA STATE
ATTORNEY GENERAL CHRIS CARR
REPORTEDLY ASKED HIM TO NOT
OPPOSE A CHALLENGE TO THE
GEORGIA ELECTION RESULTS, AND
ALISYN, WHAT WOULD A SCANDAL BE
WITHOUT RUDY GIULIANI.
WE KNOW THAT RUDY WENT IN FRONT
OF THE GEORGIA STATE LEGISLATURE
AND FRANKLY HE LIED.
HE TOLD THEM THAT 10,000 PEOPLE
IN GEORGIA HAD VOTED WHO WERE
DEAD.
THE ACTUAL NUMBER WAS TWO.
SO ALL OF THEM COULD RECEIVE
SUBPOENAS OR BE POTENTIAL
SUBJECTS.
>> I MEAN, WHAT YOU'VE JUST
DESCRIBED SOUNDS DAMMING TO MY
UNINITIATED EARS, SO WHAT WILL A
GRAND JURY DO THAT IS DIFFERENT?
>> SO IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSTAND THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN A TRIAL JURY, WE ALL
KNOW FROM WATCHING TRIALS, AND A
GRAND JURY, THE MAIN THING A
GRAND JURY CAN DO IS ISSUE
SUBPOENAS FORCING PEOPLE TO
TESTIFY.
THIS ISN'T THE CONGRESSIONAL
SUBPOENAS, YOU CANNOT MESS WITH
A GRAND JURY SUBPOENA.
A TRIAL JURY OF COURSE HAS 12
MEMBERS.
A GRAND JURY HAS 23 AS SARAH
JUST REPORTED.
A TRIAL JURY MUST BE UNANIMOUS.
IN A GRAND JURY, ALL YOU NEED IS
A MAJORITY.
IT'S MUCH EASIER TO GET THAT.
THE BURDEN OF PROOF, YOU HAVE TO
PROVE OF COURSE YOUR CASE BEYOND
A REASONABLE DOUBT TO A TRIAL
JURY, IN A GRAND JURY IT'S JUST
PROBABLE CAUSE.
OF COURSE WHAT A TRIAL JURY DOES
IS RETURN A VERDICT, GUILTY OR
NOT GUILTY.
ALL A GRAND JURY CAN DO IS ISSUE
AN INDICTMENT, AS SARA SAID,
THIS IS A SPECIAL GRAND JURY,
ALL THEY CAN DO IS ISSUE A
RECOMMENDATION THAT MAY GO TO A
REGULAR GRAND JURY, WHICH CAN
INDICT, AND TRIALS ARE PUBLIC,
YOU CAN WATCH THEM.
WE CAN PUT THEM ON TV.
GRAND JURY PROCEEDINGS ARE
NONPUBLIC SO WE WON'T KNOW
WHAT'S HAPPENING DAY BY DAY,
HOWEVER, PEOPLE WHO GET
SUBPOENAS ARE ALLOWED TO TELL US
ABOUT IT.
THEY CAN WALK OUT OF THE ROOM,
HERE'S WHAT I ASKED, HERE'S HOW
I ANSWERED, WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
A DECENT SENSE OF WHAT HAPPENED
IN THE ROOM EVEN THOUGH WE'RE
NOT IN THERE.
>> THAT'S HELPFUL.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THE JANUARY 6TH
COMMITTEE, WHAT THEY'RE DOING.
THEY HAVE NOW ASKED FOR THREE
CONGRESSMEN.
THEY NEED INFORMATION FROM THESE
GUYS.
>> THE MOST INTERESTING NEW
REVELATION IS THIS ONE,
REPRESENTATIVE ANDY BIGS, HE WAS
INVOLVED IN TALKS ABOUT
POTENTIAL PRESIDENTIAL PARDONS
FOR PEOPLE RELATING JANUARY 6TH.
WHY MIGHT SOMEONE BE INTERESTED
IN A PARDON, ONE MIGHT ASK.
THE THING IS THE COMMITTEE HAS
DECIDED, IT'S MADE CLEAR,
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO BE
SUBPOENAING FELLOW MEMBERS, THAT
WOULD PROBABLY INCLUDE THESE
THREE.
UNLESS THEY PLAY HARDBALL,
THEY'RE GOING TO BE FREE TO
SHRUG OFF REQUESTS FOR
INFORMATION.
THE THING TO REMEMBER A SUBPOENA